my hair is all like Coachella and the
rest of my body is like hey guys it is
Friday here on its grace and I did not
do a fright diary because I did not have
my well working camera with me now I do
so next week it's always fun to be
updated on the things you're not gonna
get that you have to wait for in the
future
Sports three-pointer / swan dive so
instead I want to make tumblin ask you
guys what did you want to talk about
today and someone says well they say
these are all out of order
Oh God sucks and everything's out of
order just a complete and utter oh no or
is it no oh my god oh god no how is it
oh my god oh this is the worst time did
I delete this so no oh god oh god one
stop panicking oh my god
and my backup hasn't been backed up for
188 days oh I'm having a hard time the
found a it was on my laptop not my
desktop
I hate me more than you hate me right
now how to survive Easter dinner with
the family does everyone celebrate
Easter where I'm gonna let's Google
Easter it is Sunday April 20th for 20
and Jesus I'm not used to bunny like the
Easter is a festival on holiday that was
instituted celebrate the resurrection of
Jesus Christ on the third day after his
crucifixion at Calvary as described in
the New Testament so on one hand it's
for Christians to celebrate the
resurrection of the 33 year old man that
wore robes as clothes and somehow that
has translated into a fictitious giant
rabbit human animal hybrid putting candy
in baskets inside of our homes while we
sleep see my eyes I can hardly see see
midst and I can hardly walk religion is
cool
I believe me Sam up done I can hardly do
it just sit he'll make quick do it yes
Sicily quick let's just make this a kind
of a stream of consciousness
TRADD about Easter my favorite thing
about Easter egg hunts egg hunts are
sorry Oh God
that was an aggressive laugh because I
just remembered a family story of them
so for all of you that don't know egg
hunts on Easter are stereotypically let
me know if I'm wrong on this
where families hide little plastic eggs
filled with like toys or trinkets or
change or money or something and they
hide them in a yard or some sort of like
outdoor area or indoor and you have to
race to find as many eggs as you can
find then you keep all the prizes that
are inside and one time Tim my younger
brother and I weird we were doing an egg
hunt with all of my cousins we were
definitely older than all of my cousins
and when the egg hunt started we just we
put blinders on and we got [ __ ] fun we
dominated to the point that Tim pushed
my younger cousin down face-first into
the grass so he could get a plastic egg
that had nickels inside of it and that
is why Jesus died for our sins I will
say one of my favorite things about
Easter are the chocolate like
matte-finish
candy eggs what are they called they're
so good why don't they exist all year
round they're delicious and who Fussell
Cadbury cream eggs Cadbury cream eggs
are like the bloomin onion of Easter
candy amazing in theory terrible if you
finish the entire thing good luck god
bless
what-o also it's gotten to the point
where kids go to malls and take photos
with people dressed as Easter rabbits
like a santa claus thing and they sit on
their lap I understand the Santa Claus
thing because it's a human dress as a
human hi don't officially understand the
Easter Bunny thing because it's a human
dressed as an animal allowing children
to sit on their lap and believe that it
comes in the middle of the night to
their house also donnie darko path will
be really coming up for Easter but Jake
Gyllenhaal doe I don't know
Happy Easter or not whatever you
celebrate I don't know
god bless you having a giant rabbit
break into your house and give you
chocolates what a world we live in camp
Takota calm new merch go check it out
okay yes digestive system I hear you you
exist
we get it